hey you guys movie retrospective time
this is the movie that won the poll once
again this is jeepers creepers from
2001.
now i'm wondering if people picked it
specifically because
of the
controversy surrounding the director
so let's kind of get that out of the way
because honestly i had forgotten about
this i had not seen this is so weird i
thought that i saw jeepers creepers not
back when it came out but like on cable
but when we were watching it i was just
kind of like wait a minute i don't think
i saw this one what i think i saw was
the sequel the second one because the
second one was the one with the bus and
all the people
and the creeper attacking the bus right
so i think with ray wise and [ __ ] so i
saw the second one but i never did see
the first one even though i thought i
did
what ended up happening with this
the guy that wrote and directed it his
name is victor salva
uh when this first came out he had made
a movie called clown house which i
haven't seen
and uh i guess he got in with like
francis ford coppola who helped him out
like and you know gave him money for
production he was like an executive
producer and stuff so apparently on the
set of clown house
um victor salva was caught
um
you know essentially molesting a 12 year
old who was also working on the movie
like a girl i think it was a boy oh okay
and uh so he was caught he went to
prison
um i think he got a three-year
uh sentence but he only served 18 months
15 months something like that and then
he got out and he was on parole and [ __ ]
like that so then he went on to make
powder in 1995 uh if you guys remember
that movie about the albino kid i
remember seeing that back in the day uh
and then jeepers creepers came out in
2001 and then jeepers creepers 2 came
out in 2003.
now
when these first two jeepers creepers
movies came out
we did have the internet but it wasn't
as widespread so nobody found out really
like it wasn't uh common knowledge that
he was a convicted sexual predator and
this was back in 1988 i think was when
he got caught
um nobody found out that he was a
convicted sexual predator until just
before jeepers creepers 3 came out which
was like 2017 somewhere around there so
at that point like there was like a big
stink like people were gonna like uh you
know they
after they found out about they're like
oh my god we're gonna like [ __ ]
boycott the movie or whatever but um you
know it's like i'm not saying that like
what he did was good obviously it was
terrible but he did get caught for it he
did go to prison and he hasn't been
caught since then i'm not saying that
he's not a piece of [ __ ] because he is
but
i just wanted to get that out of the way
like right because you can't and it kind
of sucks because this is actually like a
good movie it's a good movie and it's
like you can't really talk about it
without just that you know stigma being
like around it so it's like we're always
so i always kind of just wanted to like
say that from the criminals
and telling the truth man there's a lot
of that [ __ ] going on in hollywood
that's just how they are a lot of them i
i think it's many more than we according
to some of them girls off that damn
island it's more than you would ever
think and some of them are huge names
that they didn't mention but i know who
they're talking about i know they're
talking about
yeah so it's still like i said it's kind
of shitty that yeah you know that this
movie got
yep
you know it's i kind of like to
try to dissociate you know because
honestly if if we didn't watch stuff
that was made by a shitty person we
there would be nothing to watch because
most creative people have problems of
like some kind or another they're not
all pieces of [ __ ] obviously
but
there's a lot of great great works of
art you know books movies whatever that
were created by people who are terrible
people and shitty dudes that all stick
together they're like a mafia
but yeah so
so like i said that's kind of like now
interestingly it's interesting that um
we ended up doing this movie now because
i didn't actually know this going in
like when we watched it but they're
doing a reboot of it they're gonna do
like a new trilogy of this one of
jeepers creepers it's going to be
jeepers creepers reborn okay so you uh
that's always making good [ __ ] and then
[ __ ] it up by doing it again well
yeah but like i said so and victor salva
is not going to be involved in that but
they're doing like they're planning a
new trilogy the first one is supposed to
be out in 2022 like i think they've
already like finished uh you know kind
of the filming and everything like that
i think it's in post-production or
pre-burst something like that so uh i
didn't actually know that like i said
when we were going into
to do this movie i was just interested
to see it because like i said i thought
i had seen it
because i knew about
you know spoiler alert
i knew that the creeper was not a person
i knew that he was a demon and like he
had wings and stuff and i'm like well
how how would i have known that if i
hadn't seen this movie but i think i
must have seen the second one it's a
great movie
it is it's actually really really good
um i think a lot of it was borrowed from
gargoyles
it might have been um you know the tv
made for tv movie was pretty good yeah
we reviewed that a while back fun fun
movie to watch i kind of feel like well
victor salva said that and honestly some
of the stuff about it i might get into
this a little bit later but some of the
stuff like the lore around the creeper
uh you know the monster is kind of like
pennywise in it in the sense that it's
like cyclical and like he kind of like
smells people's fear and [ __ ] like that
sort of uh so it's that kind of thing
and also the beginning of it like the
first act kind of has
a little bit of like duel or the hitcher
or something like that where it's kind
of like it's almost kind of like a road
movie type at first like duel is like
somebody being chased by somebody in a
truck and you don't see them and then it
almost turns into like a stalker serial
killer thing and then it turns into like
a monster movie
because uh the creeper is not human like
he's a demon essentially but i guess he
can drive a truck huh wouldn't it wasn't
that creepy yeah truck well he had like
a human form okay
i think that
the lore around it was that like i said
it was almost like a cicada type of
thing where it was just like i think it
was every 23 years
uh every every 23rd spring
he would like re-emerge for 23 days
and he goes around like eating people
like he doesn't eat anybody he eats
people that have like a particular
uh body part that he needs like to
regenerate so i guess essentially i
haven't seen the sequels i saw the
second one but it was a long time ago i
don't really remember what happened in
it but i so i don't know if they
expanded the lore a lot more i'm sure
they probably did
but
i guess he's essentially immortal
because if he gets [ __ ] up because he
gets pretty [ __ ] up in this movie
and he eats
like somebody's body part that that's
[ __ ] up it'll regenerate like in a
very very short amount of time
yeah he does artwork with the dead
bodies too which is pretty cool that's a
good idea that is cool although they
didn't really explain why he does that
because honestly he i guess maybe he
just likes them and he because he
preserves them because some of the ones
that were there had been there for like
a really long time shop and everything
he made like a sistine looking chapel of
all these
bodies of like men and women and boys
and girls [ __ ]
and embraces and they're kind of like
chopped up and sewn together it looks
cool
creepy as [ __ ] it's not explained it's
just
some kind of weird sadism and it does
kind of seem like he he's into women and
kind of jealous of like loving
relationships and [ __ ] and wants to [ __ ]
him up and wants to i don't know maybe
wants to be a part of one or
because he does some weird stuff at the
end of the movie with this kid's body
and looks through his eyes kind of like
he he wants to be that kid to get that
girl it's kind of what it seems well
that was his sister though is that what
it was that girl was his sister
they were brother and sister yeah i
didn't know if you did that
but it just seems like
he was going to use that as a way to get
to her
although well no because he could have
taken her yeah he did but he didn't
because she didn't smell right she
didn't have
the the creeper wanted justin long the
whole pretty much the whole time because
she because he smelled him
and uh like i said he he has like
particular victims that he pick he
doesn't just eat people indiscriminately
yeah um if you have something that i
guess is maybe compatible with whatever
so he had his he got his eyes [ __ ] up
so he needed justin long's eyes yeah he
needed that character's eyes but i don't
know it's just that was the body
language that i read it looked like
he
because when she wanted to go with him
it looks like he was kind of wanting to
take her but he couldn't
and then later it looks like he was kind
of like assumed the identity of the the
the brother
as a way of getting to her that's the
way i interpreted it but you know maybe
i'm wrong no yeah i don't think that had
anything to do with it because like yeah
all the stuff they were saying about
like the lore and everything he just
picked particular
people based on
how they smelled like when they were
afraid and based on whatever body part
he needed at that time since he needed
eyes and justin long smelled better
because like i said he had an
opportunity like at the end when you
know she was saying she was trying to
save her brother by saying you know take
me instead but he was like nah and he
just took the brother instead and left
her there and she actually survives i
think that girl who's played by gina
phillips by the way her character's name
is trish i think she turns up in the
third one too
and the third one to me the eye contact
thing it looked like he wanted to take
her but couldn't like it wasn't her time
type of deal that
like he had feelings for it's weird
that's just how i interpreted it it
looked like like a longing stare and
then next then you see him later on and
he's got that same longing stare through
her through like her brother's
eyes i just thought he was gonna you
know
fantasizing
i don't know
fantasizing that he was her
that he was that boy and that's just how
i interpreted it just because they were
brother and sister doesn't mean that
demon wouldn't do that
i don't think he gave a [ __ ] about
incest that's how i just took the whole
thing as just kind of perverse
maybe i don't know i think maybe you're
like thinking about it too much because
i don't think that i don't think there
was any of that uh and i don't think
there was any of that all right i
thought was sexual so but no i don't
think i was um because honestly it's
just kind of like okay so if you haven't
seen this movie like i said it came out
in 2001.
so you got uh trish and derry which is i
guess is short for darius uh and darius
is played by justin long obviously this
i don't think this was his first movie
but he's real young in it um you know so
if you've seen like later ones that he
was in like tusk and stuff like that
yeah uh you know he's pretty young in
this yeah you know why i was thinking
that it might have been sexual because
the whole time i'm watching this movie
it's reminding me of gargoyles and that
was the situation in gargoyles he wanted
to breed with that human well maybe
that's why you were thinking that
to me it just seemed like the demon was
kind of like even though he had like a
humanoid form sort of but he just seemed
to me like uh just a predator
that was just like looking for hey i
need a leg or hey i need some eyes or
and and you smell like you're compatible
with
my body parts he was sewing couples
together and doing stuff and like well
just that one and and well just that one
and the reason that they focused on that
yeah was because that was referring back
to an urban legend that they had talked
about before about a couple that had
disappeared like 23 years earlier like
on that same road you know what i mean
so that so they were just showing hey
those those are those people that
disappeared i interpreted it as a he had
like a
sexual type fixations over this that's
how i interpreted it now that's not what
it was yeah like i said that's why they
they uh you know kind of focused on
those two because you were meant to go
oh this is the couple that disappeared
23 years ago that the urban legend is
about so it was real and that's this is
where they ended up all right the rest
of them kind of looked like that too
though but
that much on that well and the one guy
that got dumped down there it just
looked like well his stomach was cut
open because obviously like the creeper
needed whatever it was that was in there
i don't know what he took exactly he
sewed him back up didn't he
yeah i wonder why was there something in
there did he put somebody in its place i
don't think so
i don't know well like i said i i kind
of feel like maybe
the lore of it
and i kind of like that about it and
like i said maybe the lore is explored
more in the other movies because like i
said i saw the second one but it's been
a long time since i've seen it i haven't
seen the third one
so
i don't know like i said i don't really
know why he was making all these like
artistic statements with the bodies
maybe i think honestly i think it i
don't even know if if there was a reason
other than it looks cool and creepy yeah
it's funny because that's what stood out
most to me about this movie yeah i
thought it was that was really what was
significant is what he was doing with
those bodies never explained it was i
was just reading into it that i
i thought he was getting ready to try to
repopulate the world with his own kind
type of deal with a bunch of demons but
i got that from gargoyles yeah no he was
just trying to regenerate himself okay
is all he was trying to do
but uh yeah so so you have this brother
and sister
um one of them's older like trish is
older
and i guess uh darry is like on a break
i think it's supposed to be spring break
uh from college and they're driving back
to see their parents for the break and
this was actually this movie was
actually shot in and around ocala uh
mostly in marion county and i think a
little bit of it was in sumter county as
well
so that's yeah that's not very far from
us at all maybe like less than an hour
away yeah more florida movies yeah and
that's actually my mom lives in ocala so
uh so the
it's funny because the terrain i was
just kind of like yeah that looks like
ocala right yeah but yeah so so they're
driving down this sort of isolated
highway and they're just kind of like
doing brother sister [ __ ] you know
[ __ ]
making fun of each other making jokes
and [ __ ] like that like brothers and
sisters do
and uh then like i said you have kind of
an extended sequence where it's almost
kind of like a duel where this crappy
like old rickety truck yeah like from
the 30s yeah it comes up behind the car
and like seems seemingly attempting to
you know force them off the road it's
actually a real cool look at old trucks
all art deco and everything around looks
like a damn train yeah i don't know
where they got that truck it was cool i
think the wikipedia page said but i
forgot look like something from the 30s
like they said what kind of truck it was
but i can't remember they looked forward
i didn't like an american truck
yeah it was like really weirdly shaped
although like i said there were a lot of
like trucks that came out maybe in the
30s and stuff that i didn't look like a
damn front of it like a locomotive
something out of mad max it's all rusty
and [ __ ]
i liked too that they were kind of like
one of the games they were playing was
they were um trying to like uh figure
out all the license plates like all like
puns and stuff and the license plate on
this truck
said
well you think that it says
beating you but then later on like you
figure out oh it probably said be eating
you yeah you know what i mean
so i like it it took me like a couple
minutes and i was just like oh okay i
get you uh so yeah that's funny
but yeah so they're driving down the
street in florida and this guy like
tries to run them off the road there's
like kind of a big standoff just like i
said just like in duel or you know the
hitch or road game stuff like that
uh but after a while it seems like the
guy gives up and like takes off so
they're just kind of like man what the
[ __ ] was that all about that dude was
like really an [ __ ] or whatever so
then they're like driving by and then
they happen to drive by this abandoned
church
and they see the same truck parked next
to the church
and it's broad daylight and what they
see is clearly a dude like in this long
duster and hat
dumping what very very obviously seems
to be a body like wrapped in a bloody
sheet and rope and stuff down this big
ass pipe
now at this point
i will say like they do kind of um
they do kind of like
kind of lampshade this or make it or
make kind of a thing where
they make a joke about it so it doesn't
seem like such a dumb ass decision
because if you okay legitimately if you
were driving down the road a guy in a
truck had just tried to run you off the
road like really vociferously and then
you got away from um uh and then you saw
that same dude dumping what looks like a
body like down a pipe would you turn
around and go back [ __ ] no yeah call the
cops yeah i would go to the next town
and call the cops from there and be like
yeah why don't you guys go back and
check that out because i'm not gonna but
obviously this is a horror movie so
justin long's character darry
he goes yeah but you know what if one of
what if somebody that he dumped down
there because it was more than one body
was like still alive and what if it was
you wouldn't you want somebody to come
back and check on you and [ __ ] like that
i'm like yeah that's cool and everything
but call the cops you know but anyway so
so they go back
and he of course hears something down in
the pipe and he's kind of hanging down
in there and so his sister's like
holding him but then like something
comes by she's startled and he like
falls into the pipe and uh that's when
he finds all the sistine chapel of
bodies and the one person that got
dumped in there that they saw dumped
down there actually was still alive but
he you know i wasn't doing too good and
he died like a couple minutes later
movie i'm seeing this sistine chapel of
bodies and it looks like the thing i
would have alien to the alien nest yeah
i got all these ideas the damn gargoyles
so i think this dude's trying to
repopulate the damn planet with with
devil spawn well they don't actually
tell you because at first
no at first what i was gonna say is that
at first they
they don't tell you until later on that
the dude's not human yeah they're trying
to make you think that this is just like
a crazy serial killer yeah because he's
looking like he looks like a person they
don't like show his face i saw that wing
later on though
well that was kind of like the big that
was supposed to be like the big holy
[ __ ] moment in the movie where you're
like oh my god well i mean you had been
leading up to like at the end right
around the middle or end of the second
act you you're like well this dude he
has to be like super human or something
because you know they're trying to do
stuff and he's like jumping over the car
and it seems like he's doing stuff that
humans can't do
uh but then when that one wing comes out
like after that's the that's the moment
you're supposed to realize oh [ __ ] yeah
as soon as i saw that wing i was like
okay yeah it's like a gargoyle yeah and
that's that's where it all started to
come to me so so yeah so they so they
find all these bodies and [ __ ] like that
uh dairy gets out of the basement and
then they go to this diner and they try
to tell everybody in town this is a
little weird too because there's a bunch
of people in the diner so they run in
there and they're just like we just
found all these [ __ ] bodies oh my god
like give us a phone or you know let us
call the cops or something like that and
everybody in the diner like looks at
them like either like they have three
heads or
i don't know maybe because these these
people just came in here with this crazy
ass story i for a second i thought well
oh the townspeople already know and
they're just like shh you know like
don't we we just like don't talk about
that i don't really know but it doesn't
really make that clear either
so they're kind of like freaking out no
one's really doing anything about it and
then the pay phone rings now this
this to me seems like kind of um a
contentious point in the movie because
some people don't mind it some people um
you know are really bothered by it
because there's a character in this her
name's gisele
and she's a psychic
now
to me it seems like a little bit and it
doesn't bother me that much honestly but
it seems like a little bit
lazy storytelling to just introduce a
psychic who automatically knows
everything about the monster so that she
can provide exposition i mean i guess
there's worse ways to do it and like i
said it didn't really bother me that
much but i've seen some reviews that
were just kind of like yeah that was
kind of stupid like they could have
found a better way to impart the
information to them rather than just
having this like random psychic in town
being like oh yeah i saw all this stuff
in a vision and she knows about the 23
year cycle because that's what he does
this this being yeah should have magical
indian yeah that'd make a lot more sense
a magical idiot yeah yeah
well they had well they had the mad she
was magical african-americans so that's
kind of like the same kind of thing yeah
but yeah so she calls randomly because
she knew where they were going to be i
guess and it's just like you know if you
hear that song jeepers creepers because
that's that song from the 1930s was um
maybe that's why his truck was from
there maybe he thought his truck was
from the 30s because that song is from
the 30s yeah that's 30s art deco looking
truck yeah but she basically says if you
hear that song you're in trouble because
i had a vision
of
dary like darius screaming somewhere and
that in a little room and and that song
is on so if you hear that song get the
[ __ ] out of wherever you are because
that means you're like in big trouble
so they don't believe her obviously
because it sounds nuts
but then as i said the you know the
creeper comes and like attacks him
because apparently he really likes the
way that darius smells and once i mean
the psychic even says once he
gets uh you know he sniffs you and he
likes that smell he's gonna like just
follow you like forever until he gets
all your organs or whatever ones that he
wants
so
you're kind of like because i didn't
realize and i was kind of thinking about
this earlier
so
would the creeper have come after
uh darry and trish
if they hadn't seen him dumping those
bodies
i kind of feel like he probably still
would have because he was still chasing
them like with even before any of that
happened so i guess he had just like
smelled him and was just kind of like oh
yeah i need to like find out more about
that dude but then like when they saw
the bodies he's like oh well now i
really have to like you know what i mean
because he could have killed trish too
but he didn't
so i don't know so i kind of feel like
maybe
them just being on that road being at
the wrong place at the wrong time they
were just kind of [ __ ] either way like
i don't think there's any way they could
have avoided it
so so yeah so basically like the last
half of it or the last act
is the creeper
uh you know chasing after the two of
them and the psychic like meeting up
with them at this police station and her
trying to like
tell what like you know what her dreams
and visions were so they can like avoid
getting eaten by it
one thing that i do actually like about
this one again this is a spoiler alert
but this is an old ass movie it's 20
years
is doesn't seem like it though uh yeah
yeah i like that he that uh
that they went with uh a sad ending
yeah because justin long's character
darry dies
yeah um his sister does actually try to
uh have the monster take her instead but
the monster doesn't want her
and um
you know and he basically takes he takes
them back to the layer well his new
layer because his old layer you know the
cops found out about it so he burned it
down so he goes to a new layer
and the last shot
is
you know that is him like with the
justin long's body hanging up
and it looks like he's hollowed out the
back of his head
and taking taking his eyeballs well yeah
i got a whole body almost you guys i was
earlier i was watching a review it's
like half an hour long or something i
was watching another review i think it's
the horror show
it's two guys and two girls and they
were talking about this movie and they
had legitimately like a 10 minute
argument
over whether
over whether the monster just took the
guy's eyes or if he hollowed the body
out i think he held it i'm like he
clearly hollowed it out because you
could see the background through the eye
holes
and it's like
and it's funny because the one guy that
had just watched the movie like the
night before he's like no he just took
his eyeballs and all the other ones are
like no he hollowed out or at least he
hollowed out the head yeah because you
could see the background like through
the eye eye socket
it looked to me like he hollowed dude
was try her body it looked i mean at
least he did his head yeah it was
standard yeah have it up on like a
platform well and the thing
the thing too was like
the other bodies looked like they were
kind of partially preserved they almost
look like porcelain well remember some
[ __ ] was dropping
yeah so i kind of yeah i kind of feel
like maybe he had like resin or
something like that i thought he had
made some kind of like you know like
those [ __ ] you know like when they
did those corpses for uh you know those
weird body exhibits like at the museums
but they they had like plasticine yeah i
thought it was something like that
although more like porcelain because it
looked like the bodies were like
porcelain sort of like it had some kind
of preservative on it so i kind of
figured he had either hollowed out the
whole body and put preservative on it or
he had just hollowed out the head
and
preserved it after that so it's just it
was really funny to me because when i
was watching the horror show like the
one guy that had watched all three
movies like the night before they
recorded it was adamant that it's like
no it was just the eyes that were gone
and everybody else was like dude you're
tripping yeah it's like the
you can see the background clearly
and then like he comes up and like looks
through the eye hole yeah he's dumb i'm
like yeah
you know i'm like i he at least look
took out the whole [ __ ] back of the
head or whatever i mean because you
can't see the background like through if
you just take somebody's eyeballs out
there's a whole bunch of skull and brain
back there i had i had the feeling the
impression that he hollowed out the
entire whole back of the body that's
what i thought too shell you almost on
the front yeah front parts of the sides
yeah maybe he took a bunch of his well
because i don't know because
he needed his eyes for sure
but
you know like the one great scene where
trish
is just running the creeper over like
over and over again which like i said is
good because in a horror movie they just
run them over and they're like oh it's
pretty he's probably dead let's go but
she's just like no [ __ ] that she's
backed over and ran over back over right
it was like oh until he was like
squooshed
um she didn't know that he was a demon i
mean because that would kill a regular
person but then the creeper goes and
invades the police station and starts
eating
like he eats a leg and an arm off one of
the prisoners because that's his arm and
leg were squished so he's like
regenerating himself by eating those
parts that he needed so
so i don't know like what he does with
all the extra
body parts but he seems to like to keep
them
yeah he seems to like to keep them but
they they definitely are preserved
because they said some of the bodies
down there looked like they'd been there
a long time and that couple had been in
there for 23 years yeah because they had
gone missing 23 years before like on
that same road so
i mean this is actually for for um the
early 2000s i kind of feel like i don't
really like a lot of the early 2000s
horror movies um a lot because a lot of
them were remakes
and uh you know were kind of like shitty
remakes of like classic ones
and i didn't love that yeah and a lot of
them were just kind of like pg-13 or
kind of like teen kind of stuff which
this one's kind of like that too
but it's a little weirder though it's a
little weirder i like that it has like
three different like i said i like that
it goes from like a road movie to like a
stalker serial killer type movie into
like a monster movie so i kind of
thought that was kind of cool i actually
really liked um you know the the banter
between justin long and gina phillips
they actually really did seem like
brother and sister to me uh so i really
liked the relationship between the two
of them i know some people find them
annoying i did not
um
they didn't seem annoying to me uh but i
i can see there were a lot of movies
that came out around this time period
that did have like really annoying like
young adult characters but i didn't find
them annoying in this and like i said i
really liked their kind of like back and
forth the brother and sister type thing
and i liked that they made them brother
and sister so they didn't shoot horn in
some kind of like ooh sexual tension
blah blah blah i like that they did a
brother and sister now interestingly i
don't know if this is the case but a lot
of people have speculated that back in
the early 90s
there was actually a case that was kind
of similar to the beginning of this
movie where there was a brother and
sister i think it happened in michigan
it was a brother and sister and they
were driving you know somewhere
and they saw somebody like a guy
dumping a body like behind an abandoned
building or a church or something like
that and they reported it to the police
and it turned out that that guy had
killed his wife
and so these two people who just
happened to be driving by who were
brother and sister like saw him
and so the cops went to get him and then
there was like a big shootout and he
killed himself
so a lot of people there's some other
details too that were kind of the same
but uh you know a lot of people
speculated that was maybe one of the
ideas for this although the director
said has never confirmed or denied that
but i thought that was kind of
interesting that case i read an article
about it yeah it was like a dude that
killed his wife but somebody drove by
and saw the [ __ ] body but yeah i mean
other than
you know and like i said i guess it's
true of like most horror movies if
people didn't make stupid decisions um
you know no horror movies would happen
probably
the one decision of him being like well
we saw a guy dumping bodies down a pipe
let's go back and see like let's go
check that out um at least it wasn't
night time uh most normal people would
not do that uh so i thought like the
justification for that was a little lame
but like i said that didn't really
bother me all that much it's just like a
fun
monster movie and honestly like one of
the best ones that came out in this era
i think and i'm glad that i finally it's
weird that i thought that i'd seen it
but i hadn't some people like the second
one better
i kind of feel like the second one was
pretty good too the second one i think
was more straightforward it was just
like a bus that was stranded on that
stretch of road and then it was like
near the end of the creeper's cycle you
know what i mean like he was gonna go
back into
uh into whatever like into hibernation
like in a day or two so they were trying
to like hold out until that happened um
and i remember that being good but i
haven't seen the third one so i don't
really know what's going on with that so
like i said they they are making a new
one like a
a reboot or sql trilogy or something
like that and the first one is supposed
to be out in 2022 although i'm not sure
when i think that it has been
shot like i think it has been filmed but
i don't know like when it's gonna come
out so you know
uh but yeah so you liked it right oh
yeah i liked it yeah it's good i thought
it was pretty good it's just like a fun
it's like a fun monster movie yeah and
you know i've
it's kind of movie where you know i was
just watching it i wasn't paying super
close attention to all the details i
still had i still had a fun with it
because it's shot real well it's got a
good um
score
the edits good
it's got likable characters in it it's
creepy it shows you some [ __ ] up
imagery my imagination was kind of
running wild with with it in certain
spots i was imagining things that
weren't there according to jenny but
i thought at the end when he was looking
through the damn face that he had a plan
to go back and get her somehow that's
what i thought it was see i don't think
that ever happens though i thought i
mean i think she does turn up in some of
the later ones i don't know
i don't know if he was maybe gonna use
that that kid's body yeah i thought it
was gonna happen but i mean just not not
to get her but just because he needed a
new one i don't really know i don't i
don't know how like i said they never
really say what he is no they don't
explain it he's kind of like a demon
that's good that they do
they're not even sure and he's got
things on him to kind of unfold the more
pissed off he gets more of him kind of
gets exposed yeah i liked that like with
the little things coming out his head i
thought that looked really cool
actually you know what they actually i
forgot to mention this they actually
wrote that role of the monster for lance
hendrickson okay but then he couldn't do
it right um so they got this other guy
to do it and uh what was his name i
can't remember it's in here somewhere
but um yeah it's just
it's just a good monster you know what i
mean it's just it's a cool monster and
it's shot really well it's like high
quality yeah jonathan breck that was the
name of the guy that played the monster
but yeah it was originally written for
uh lance hendrickson but then he could
he couldn't do it he didn't say anything
did he no um uh in the first cut of the
film i think he had one line of dialogue
but they cut it out because they thought
it would be better if he didn't talk
yeah um which i agree with that honestly
well like you said monsters are better
when they're mysterious so if they talk
or if you
demystify them too much then they're not
really scary anymore so like you said i
kind of like that they didn't really
explain
she's trying to shake
she's digging through the book um they
didn't really explain
okay knock it off pokey yeah they didn't
really explain like where but that's
kind of more realistic because you
wouldn't know if this just happened
every 23 years and people disappeared
just mysteriously and never turned up
anywhere um you know and maybe some
urban legends like came about but you
wouldn't know like who that how would
you know that and i mean the only reason
that anybody knew anything about it was
because of the psychic like she knew so
which like i said i guess there are
worse ways to get that across um you
know
she's going to dig through the books
well you can't stop her
i mean she's just going to do it yeah
but yeah so uh what does everybody think
about this movie uh
can you watch it knowing what the
director did um you know i had actually
forgotten about it until i looked it up
later i was just like oh yeah that's
that guy i remembered it more like after
something when i was reading something
about powder
director's just one person on that team
man a lot of people worked on this
that's what i mean in a way in a way
it's kind of like easier to justify it
like when it's a movie because like you
said yeah that's just one dude yeah he's
the director but a bunch of people
involved yeah there's actors there's
screenwriters there's you know although
he yeah there's a whole crew of people
although he's the screenwriter on this
too but but yeah so yeah this is like a
pretty decent uh flick and i'm actually
surprised i hadn't uh seen it before now
so i'm glad i finally got to see it so
uh tell us what you think about it in
the comments and we will see you guys on
the next one
bye